[Applause]
it's only three days into his presidency
and pedro castillo is already facing
protests angry
at his choice of prime minister
[Applause]
criminal terrorists want to rule the
country it's not fair that a terrorist
as prime minister
that's why we're protesting
we will not allow terrorists to take
over our country
is being investigated for an alleged
apology for terrorism
which is a crime in peru in an interview
earlier this year
he defended members of the shining path
the maoist rebel group that killed
tens of thousands of people from the
1980s onwards
castillo's choice of vegido for prime
minister or cabinet chief
as it's known in peru sent shockwaves
around the country
the stock market dropped along with the
value of peru's currency against the
dollar
critics also say other new ministers
have no
experience in government
we can't say it's a lack of intelligence
experience or that he's never governed
and that's why he's making all these
mistakes no
i think there is much more to it because
the president signaled his divisiveness
and all peruvians will bear the brunt of
his irresponsibility
well many people here say they didn't
vote for castillo but many who did are
expressing their anger through social
media
saying they voted for him to rule for
the people and not
for the political party he represents so
far
president castillo has also visited
victims of an earthquake
in the north of the country telling
supporters he'll focus on those left
behind
there are people who have been left
behind for a very long time
we can't do much if we don't prioritize
our health care we will give mayors and
regional governors
a better budget
many peruvians want castillo to deliver
the changes he promised
during his election campaign but it'll
be hard for them
to trust the president who they say has
been making mistakes
from day one mariana sanchez al jazeera
lima peru